is going on dude a whole lotta whole lot
of what a whole lot of this
love and appreciation no whole lot of
this self doubt and questioning oh okay
a whole lot of this insecurity yeah
what a disembarrassment
fake rolex that's oh yeah so tell me
about this all right so the juice of it
is after my last show in boston there's
this guy he's like waiting around for a
while probably at least an hour walk out
there and he's like hey man let's show
this and then but i just want you to
have this takes this rolex off his wrist
and he hands it to me i don't know it's
a rolex as he's taking it off passes it
to me i look at it i just see the
letters r-o-l i'm like
the first thing i say is this is fake
right i say this a couple times he's
like no no look look let's open the
class i'm like okay he's like look
that's the
serial number right there and i don't
know [ __ ] about rolex's so i kind of
take it at face value i go okay you
didn't ask why i was so bewildered by
the whole thing by the fifth show i'm
wasted mentally because er everything
blurs oh yeah by the time i'm walking
out like someone could be like hey
there's a gold car outside with your
name on it i'd be like for sure
someone could easily kidnap you yeah
this is what you're saying yeah they
just have to wait till after the fifth
show the weekend yo i'm your uber driver
oh okay yo your mom's waiting for you in
this car oh mommy bet yeah mommy mommy
i'm sorry mommy then he says the
funniest thing to me well you know i
just graduated from duke like cody okay
so you know i think oh cody's a dude
graduate i've seen him do dumb things
with money maybe this is real okay
and so i'm still like not believing this
[ __ ] the guy leaves you like you
accepted this game no no no no sorry i'm
trying to get through it but no i try to
like give it back okay good and he keeps
going like no then he like drops like
the duke thing as if to say i have money
so he will not take the watch back he's
like i don't want it i want you to have
it he says like something to the tune of
like you've like impacted my life i just
want you to have it okay so i'm sort of
like all right i shake his hand and they
leave kind of sick though it is but i'm
still weirded out and then tom being tom
he's like the [ __ ] is going on here man
he's like that thing's cursed that's
from his like dead uncle or something we
shouldn't have this like he's really
bugged out by it okay and i'm staring at
it in my hand and then i'm like this has
to be fake right the five of us are kind
of like it'd be really weird to stand
around for an hour sit there and like
give me the whole now you've like
impacted my life just to give me a fake
watch it feels so bizarre so we're kind
of like i guess it's real and again i
don't know [ __ ] about rolex's in my mind
i'm like oh maybe this thing's worth a
couple grand i know they can be
expensive but i'm not thinking it's what
i end up finding out it is hold on i'm
standing in the lobby and i'm looking at
it and i look up and he's standing in
the window like watching me waiting for
his uber and he's like kind of chuckling
and he like waves and i like gesture it
to him like take this back
he's like
it's
then he just shot up into the sky
yeah he's just in the window like this
now he was waving and then he like got
slammed into the window yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
and his eyes like rolled up in his head
and then like a hand started reaching
through the skin in his chest and you're
telling tom and cash and they're like
sure dude sure that happened no i just
saw it i can see him i can see him there
like there's no one out there there dude
when he's standing in the window and he
like waves again tom like he had had it
give me that thing takes it like storms
out i just come outside i just hear the
tail end of it where tom's like you're
making it [ __ ] weird dude you're
making it weird yelling at the guy yeah
he is and then the guy's like oh then
i'm weird it's fine give it to the
bartender whatever makes you happy just
you know just take it and he gets in the
uber and he leaves tom is standing there
holding the watch and he's just shaking
his head he's like wouldn't take it back
he's like i don't know man i think that
thing's bad juju and he's cursed i'm
like wearing it put it on yeah i put it
on put on a cursed watch [ __ ] yeah i put
on a cursed watch what's wrong with you
yeah you liked it too of course i did
because it was cool oh he likes it oh i
like this this really is a horror movie
like something about it you're like i
like this thing yeah it's like frodo in
the ring the humbleness any bit of it i
had just disappeared and i'm like it's
just gross
i'm pointing at people more crazy
impression i'm pointing at people more
yeah yeah now that i have it on i'm like
hey just not even subtle rolex by the
way
good to see you rolex
i'll have the uh
yeah the number one and i was pointing
at people like i'd walk down the street
i'd be like you lay on your back i want
to [ __ ] on your chest you know and then
they'd do it
they'd be like yes of course so i'm
liking the watch i'm like i guess it's
real
[ __ ] it so now it's gone on a few days
and then i talk about it with ben i knew
there'd be like some watch guys that
would like comment and so i'm reading
the comments and then one guy he leaves
two specific model numbers he's like hey
man if that's real it's either this or
this and i bet you that serial number
comes back stolen so then i like copy
and paste the serial numbers and the
ebay listings for that same watch are
like 26 to 32 000 so i'm like okay at
this point i'm flying to vancouver and
i'm like there's literally no way this
is real okay the watch is pretty [ __ ]
rare and if you had that you would not
just
i feel like you'd have some appreciation
for it unless you graduated from duke
yeah yeah in which case money ain't [ __ ]
to you yeah exactly yeah so i land in
vancouver i find a jeweler that's like
20 minutes from the airport and we take
it to this jeweler and i'm thinking it's
gonna be a long process i just hand it
to him through his little coveted window
i'm like yo man someone try to pass this
off to me is real can you tell me if
it's fake he just puts in his hand he's
like it's fake
and i say damn it and he's like i'm 99.9
sure i was like yeah do you mind just
cracking open the movement and verifying
he goes yeah sure he takes this thing
that seriously looks like it's for
walnuts literally like busting my balls
puts it on the back and he goes like
opens it yeah it's fake the back is
plastic
and he hands it back to me so then we
walk out and i'm like i'm like not only
was it fast it was like someone just
like sucked my dick in under 0.3 seconds
it got yanked out of the rich people
matrix okay right i can feel everyone
laughing
they felt how much i changed as a person
they were like this is good for you you
should have never had that watch you're
a bad person
my opener desired he's just beaming at
me with his stupid eyes he's so elated
he's like i'm the happiest i've ever
been it's fake
did you feel like a little bit of a
doofus wearing around a fake roll of
course yeah but i'll hold this l
publicly i don't care no that's that's
fair yeah you definitely feel like an
idiot yeah because you're like alright
because when you i got duped that's not
only that you put that [ __ ] on and like
you think you're a cool person yeah and
you're not you're a [ __ ] yeah
so then it just becomes my fidget
spinner for three days as i just get
over the fact that it's like because you
can't give it away something about it no
i i actually coming back you wake up and
it's on you're like what the didn't i
give this to the guy i threw it out my
window i went to take a piss it was
wrapped around my dick
whoa it's just what the hell
yeah it's a countdown and then when i
move my massive dick out of view of the
toilet the kid who gave it to me is
drowning in the toilet he's like
[Laughter]
then i'm wrestling it off my huge dick
i'm like i don't understand what the
[ __ ] what is this weird prank did the
kid not know it was fake no i think he
knew and so why did he do that i don't
know because he's weird i maybe thought
it'd be funny it's not funny it is funny
well to give someone a watch and then
just see them very publicly believe that
it's real it's hilarious yeah
that's something i would do yeah maybe
it is kind of no it's brain it's so
funny what's even funnier is i had to
upload a youtube video where i wore it
after i knew that it was fake and i
think that was the funniest part you
were wearing it in the video in a video
yeah just waving it in front of it yeah
yeah i was like
make sure you like and subscribe
so i got got it's funny though i don't
feel bad for two reasons when like i
don't know [ __ ] about watches and then
when i initially googled it the range
was so wide that i was like i don't know
maybe we got it for a couple grand and
like he just doesn't care about money
maybe he's crypto rich nowadays i don't
think he'd be giving away any assets
this is before the big crash okay so i
went back to my roots 100 casio nice
you